I think the fast and furious world of
Wall Street has a little in common with
the graceful and gorgeous world of
ballet better not tell that to Goldman
Sachs partner Valentino Carlotti he is
the patron of the one and only misty
Copeland perhaps the fastest rising star
in the world of dance and some say in
the world of sport earlier this week she
became the first african-american woman
to be named the principal dancer at the
American Ballet Theatre Copley Copeland
backer Valentino Carlotti is with us now
Valentino when we think of a Goldman guy
the guy who spent the last five years
running Goldman's Brazil division I'm
not sure we draw a parallel to a woman
ballerina how'd you even get in this
game well first of all you began with
saying she was incredibly elegant I wish
we were half as elegant that she is but
you know it's between tea I came into
your building and when I came through
the building they asked me hey we know
who you are how do you know who we are
Who I am
well we've got your ID we prepped for
you that spoke to a certain culture in a
way of doing things right one of these
are attracted me about misty as of
watching her dance is what does it take
to perform at that level to do a day in
day out to have that kind of excellence
to have that kind of grace to do the
work that she does in the precise way
that she does that I could learn from
and apply to myself of course
I don't have you ever seen her dance
she's incredibly beautiful her dance is
incredibly beautiful and she creates
beauty on a daily basis did you ever
think she was going to have the cultural
impact she has or in sports if you think
about it yesterday misty on the cover of
the New York Times
she's an Under Armour's signed athlete
they had the number one advertisement in
their history because of misty not Tom
Brady not Steph Curry not Jordan speith
did you think she was going to have this
kind of impact on the world well you
know the interesting thing about misty
is she's always focused on dance and
that's why she's doing it so so that is
her North Star she's always focusing how
can I perform well so you never think
about okay making principal or what the
impact is going to be but of course as a
black woman dancing in a profession
that's you have this very few black
woman if any at her level of course you
know that if she reached this level it
was going to
amazing and have a huge impact you do
see that we attend the shows and watch a
dance the audience is incredible and
diverse to come see your dances have you
have you always been a fan of the ballet
because you'd expect a goldman-sachs
partner more likely to team up with
jordan Spieth you know bankers play golf
but the ballet as popular as it is in
the sort of upper classes and elite here
in New York is not really the average
guys kind of game well I was an athlete
all my life growing up as well playing
basketball football soccer so athletics
was something I was always attracted to
me but I came from a family that
emphasized being a well-rounded person
getting into the arts literature science
math and frankly when I was a younger
guy my niece was a dancer and we should
always play around doing ballets and she
was the ballerina and I was her partner
so I've always meant like dance always
attended dance and again if you've ever
seen a ballet certainly a ballet that
misty has performed in it's just
incredible and beautiful what does her
success mean to the african-american
community you know it's just another
example of showing that all pursuits are
for all peoples right and it just
removes the barrier that people might
have if you can't do something because
of your skin color or your ethnicity or
your race of your culture and so of
course the entire black community is
incredibly proud and misty you know we
asked how come you talk about being a
black dancer all the time she says well
because it's part of who I am it is Who
I am and that's part of her story in her
journey and it has it had implications
in how she has come on this path you've
said a great dancer could be a great
thing yeah why I mean the things they
have to do if you ever go and see them
rehearse first of all they're rehearsing
eight nine hours a day I see a lot of
fat bankers the work hold on let me get
maybe there's eight nine hours a day
they take class every day but to do that
day-in day-out and to operate at a level
of excellence on a day to day basis in
chrome so as a banker at Goldman Sachs
we're in the pursuit of excellence we're
trying to do the best we can we try to
serve our clients the best we can the
ethic we try to promote in our people is
pursuit of excellence first-class you
know a product all the time and so if
you watch misty and you watch it
performing you want to prepare or any of
the
the rigor they have the discipline they
have the preparation they have the
mental toughness they have the physical
toughness they have for me it's
incredibly inspiring and I constantly
looked to learn from that is there a
parallel I mean you went into the world
of Investment Banking where there very
few african-americans misty went into
dancing very cute african-american
dancers do you feel a connection a
kinship to the road children are of
course you know in fact you know the
career path is almost the same there's
the court of LA the soloist the
principal at Goldman is the analyst the
associate vice president managing
director partner so that track is is
similar almost identical in title and
there are you know still too few people
of color on Wall Street still too few
women on Wall Street so you can't but
you'll feel an affinity for someone like
misty well you're changing it so's misty
congratulations thank you so much
Goldman Sachs partner Missy Colvin
patron Valentino Carlotta